ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะคุณผู้หญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันศุกร์
ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
13 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพตอะไรคะปีพตต
ปีคศอะไรคะปีค.ศ 2002  2 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดี
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 42 ค่ะเดือน
เดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ
ปีคศปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะกะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 14
เดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 กะปีคศ
ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครู
ฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
11:00 น
4 โมงกี่นาที
11:00 น 42 นาทีค่ะ
11:42 นาทีก็เป็นเวลากลางวันมาหาเป็นตอน
กลางวัน
ตอนกะสายใส่ค่ะก็ครูคิดว่านักเรียนนัก
เรียนนักเรียนเนี่ยรู้จักครูฟ้าอะไรครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยบอกว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยบ้านเนาะบ้าน
อยู่พัทยา
ในบ้านฟ้าอยู่พัทยาค่ะคุณหญิงธิญามีอะไร
คะครูฟ้า
พัทยามีทะเลหาสาระพัทยามีทะเลทะเลทะเลก็
จะมีต้น
ต้นมะพร้าวเนาะทะเล
ใช่น่าจะเห็นน่ะทะเล
ดีแล้วครูฟ้าอยู่พัทยาอยู่ทะเล
ที่ทะเลที่พัทยาเนี่ยมีอันนี้ไหมคะ
อะไร
เรือ
มีเรือเหลือแล้วครูฟ้าถ้าเป็นครูฟ้าใช่
ไหมครูฟ้าเนี่ยนี้กูฟ้า
แล้วก็ครูฟ้ามีนั่งอยู่ที่เรือ
แล้วก็ขายเรือครูฟ้าพายเรือได้ไหม
ฟ้าภัยเรือ
ได้นิดหน่อยโห
เก่งว่าดีเลยค่ะครูฟ้าทำไมคะผู้หญิงผู้
หญิงจะให้มาทำอะไรเอาวันนี้เนี่ยครูหญิง
ก็จะมีเรื่องจะมาเล่าให้ครูฟ้าฟังเกี่ยว
กับทะเล
เรือนี้แหละค่ะแล้วก็ครูฟ้าต้องเป็นคน
ถ่ายเรือในเรื่อง
ครูฟ้าก็ต้องเลือดใช่ไหมมีถอยให้ครูฟ้า
ต้องเลือด
ฮะอะไรนะคะอยากรู้ค่ะครูหญิงว่า
เป็นยังไงอันนี้เป็น
ทะเลมหาทะเลเนาะทะเลเนี่ยเป็นน้ำหมอสี
ทะเลต้องสีฟ้าใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้า
ทะเลต้องสีฟ้าค่ะอันนี้สีฟ้ามาให้ฟ้า
น้ำเงิน
พระๆทะเลสีฟ้านะคะน้ำทะเลเนี่ยเวลากิน
เป็นยังไงคะอ่ะคือเข็มเข็มไม่กินอ่ะทะเล
ก็มีปลาฉลามน้องอ่ะไม่เห็นฉลามนะคะ
ปาส
ใช่ไหมค่ะอะอันนี้เนี่ยชี้ทะเลนะแล้วก็มี
หรือเรือ
จากระยะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะ
แป๊บนึงนะคะนักเรียน
หน้าเรือครูฟ้าที่นี้ใช่ไหมแล้วก็ครูปลา
เนี่ยจะพายเรือนะคะไปที่
ไปที่เกาะหมอไม่เห็น
กินน้ำเกาะเห็นชิเกาะ
เกาะอันนี้นะคะอ่ะกูฟ้าเนี่ยสะพายเรือจาก
ทะเลพัทยาสนจากพัทยาต่อไปที่เกาะสมัยพาย
เรือไปที่เกาะ 5 อ่าแล้วก็บนเรือ
ที่บนเรือ
แล้วผู้หญิงจะขยายเรือให้ให้นักเรียนก่อน
เนาะจ่ายค่ะคุณ
บนเรือนะคะบนเรือเนี่ยก็มีคนอยู่บนเรือ
ค่ะครูฟ้ามีกี่คนคะผู้หญิงคนดีคนมีคน
มามีคนเนี่ยผู้ชาย
ผู้หญิงทั้งหมด
4 คน
ตาย
คนเรียน 4 คนพายเรือไปที่เกาะใช่ไหมตาย I
มีคน 4 คนใช่ไหมหาก็มีอยู่ที่บ้านใช้อยู่
บนเรือ 4 คนมีใครบ้างคะก็มี
ครูฟ้าต้องมีครูฟ้านะคะครูป่า
สาวยีผมเป็นยังไงคะอ่า
มัดของครูฟ้านะกรูฟ้าเนี่ยเป็นคน
ว่าป้าโตแล้วเบนซ์ตาแว่นตา
กูมาใส่แว่นตาไงอ่ะอันนี้ครูฟ้าค่ะ
อย่างวะ
กูเขาบอกไม่ชอบผู้หญิงไหว้ครูฟ้ากูฟ้า
เนี่ยเป็นคน
ขายเรือขายเรือนะคะครูฟ้าเรือเรือเรือลำ
นี้เป็นของครูฟ้านกรุ๊ปเธอเป็นคนพายเรือ
แล้วก็มีครูฟ้าใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็มีที่ 1 วัน
ที่ 2 มีเด็ก
กูฟ้าชอบเด็กผู้ชายเด็กผู้ชายหรือว่าเด็ก
ผู้หญิง
เด็กผู้หญิงอ่ะโอเคงั้นเด็กผู้ชายอ้าวครู
หินทำไมทำแบบนี้เล็กไปไหมเด็กผู้ชายเนี่ย
ก็โอเคกับผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิงโอเคอ้ามีเด็ก
มีเด็กผู้ชายนะคะเด็กผู้ชายก็อายุ 6 ขวบ
สมัยของขวบก็คือเด็กน้องเด็กๆอ่ะคนที่สอง
เนี่ยเด็กผู้ชาย
คนที่สามหล่ะคนที่ 3 เนี่ยก็เป็นผู้หญิง
เราเป็นผู้หญิงอ่ะ
ถ้าเป็นผู้หญิงสหแล้วก็
แก่แล้วเป็นคนแก่
เป็นคนแก่นะคนแก่ก็
อายุประมาณ
65 ปีอายุ 65 ปีคนที่ 3 เป็นคนแก่ค่ะ
คนแก่อ่ะคนที่ 4 หรอผู้หญิงคนที่ 4 เนี่ย
อาเป็นผู้ชายแล้วกันเป็นผู้ชายเป็นผู้ชาย
แล้วก็เป็นผู้ชายที่แข็งแรง
สายแข็งแรงเป็นผู้ชายแข็งแรงก็คือแบบมี
กล้ามมีกล้าม
โอ้นี่ไม่ใช่ปู่ไม่ใช่กุ้งแล้วคะ
ไปเป็นผู้ชายมีซิกแพคเขื่อนเป็นผู้ชาย
แข็งแรงก็อายุประมาณ
35 ปีแล้วกันจะได้ไม่ต้องอายุเท่าครูฟ้า
บนเรือเนี่ยมีคน 4 คนป้ะก็คือมีครูฟ้า
มีเด็กก็มีใครคะคนแก่แล้วก็ผู้ชาย
แข็งแรงแต่ผู้ชายแข็งแรงนะคะก็ครูฟ้าก็จะ
พายเรือพาคนทั้งหมดเนี่ยมาที่เกาะใช่ไหม
คะแล้วก็คือฟ้ากำลังพายเรือพายเรือไปก็มี
ล้ม
ลมลมมีผู้ชมแปลงไหมแรงมีลมแรงมากๆเรือกู
ฟ้าเนี่ยโอ้โห
ไม่โอเคมีลมเสร็จแล้ว
ยังมีอีกค่ะครูฟ้ามีอะไรอีกคะผู้หญิงมีฝน
หะฝนฝนฝนๆฝนตกแบบ
ไม่ใช่ฝนตกปรอยๆนะถ้าอันนี้เนี่ย
ฝนตกปรอยๆใช่ไหมนิดหน่อยรอยๆๆแล้วอะไรฝน
แบบไหนคะผู้หญิงโฟนตกแรงมากฝนตกหนักไหม
[เพลง]
ซ่าๆมีฝนตกหนักมีลมแรงๆเราเรียกอะไรครู
ฟ้าเราเรียกว่า
พายุทรายถ้าไม่ใช่มั้ยมีพายุก็น่าจะคล้าย
ๆกับ Perry  kane สมัยเฮอริเคนเนี่ยก็
เป็นแบบบู
พายุนะเค้าครูฟ้าครูฟ้ากำลังพายเรือมีลม
พายุมีฝน
มาโครฟ้าเนี่ยก็คิด
ทำ
ไส้เรือเนี่ยมันหนักสมัยมันหนักมีคนคนคน
คน 4 คนเนี่ยไม่โอเคว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยหนักนะ
50 กิโลกรัมถึงไหมคะถึงถ้าผู้หญิงโอเค
หนูว่างนะคะเด็กเนี่ยนอาจหนังสมุดเด็ก
อายุ 6 ขวบก็หนักสรรค์เท่าไหร่ 30 มั้ย
เออมา 34 เด็กเนี่ย 3 เด็กเหมือนหนักสา 4
30 กิโลกรัมคนแก่ผู้หญิงก็น่าจะประมาณ
อ่ะ
60 กิโลกรัม
กูผู้ชายแข็งแรง
ก็น่าจะหนักประมาณ
80 มั้ย
80  90 คิดว่าน่าจะมันเก้าสิบมั้ยน้องหา
คนนี้เนี่ยก็หนัก 90 กิโลกรัม
โว้รวมกันเนี่ย
มากกว่า
กิโลกรัม
เงือกไหมเรือหนักไหมเรือหนักคะผู้หญิง
หนักมากไง 200 กิโลกรัมใช่ไหมเรือหนักมาก
ครูฟ้าไม่โอเคครูฟ้าก็ต้องคิดอ้า 4 คน
อยู่บนเรือมี
ถ้ามึงพายุไม่ได้หน้ากรูฟ้าคิดว่าเรือ
จากสี่
ทำไมมี 4 คนต้องเหลือ
3 คน
3 คนเนี่ยต้องมี
อุ้ยแต่ตอนนี้นะคะลบนี้เอาก่อนเนาะ 3 คน
ใช่ไหมคะสามคนเนี่ยก็ต้องมีครูฟ้าว่ากูก็
เป็นคนพายเรือ
แล้วก็ต้องบวกอีก
122 คน
หา
อีกหนึ่งคนไม่ได้นานได้แค่ 3 คนเท่านั้น
ใช่หาแต่บนเรือเนี่ยมีคน 4 คนใช่ไหมมี
เด็กคนแก่คนแข็งแรง
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องเลือกก็ช่วยช่วย
สองคนจะช่วยสองคน
ทิ้ง
หนึ่งคนต้องทิ้ง 1 คนช่วยสองคน
นี้คนสามคนครูฝางจะหีงกดเนี้ยคนเนี้ยทิ้ง
ไม่เอาไม่
ลงน้ำคู่ฟ้าจะทิ้ง
ใครแล้วก็จะช่วยใคร
มีบาส
AV เด็กไม่มีอ่ะโอเคพระเอกก็ดีค่ะโอเค a
เด็กเด็ก
ดีคนแก่
แกะซีคนแข็งแรงคุณ
ครูฟ้าจัดทิ้งใครจะช่วยใคร
กูฟ้าคิด
เราต้องคิดคิดคิด
ของยาแขวนช่วยสองคน
ทิ้งบ๊ายบาย
ทิ้งหนึ่งคนที่ฟ้าได้ไม่ได้
เพราะว่าเด็กแดกคนแก่คนแข็งแรงพายเรือไม่
ได้พายเรือไม่เป็นท่าทิ้งครูฟ้าทั้งหมด
ตายไง่งั้นครูฟ้าคิดว่า
ผู้ชายแข็งแรงค่ะอ๋อครูฟ้าเนี่ยผู้ชาย
แข็งแรงเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็ตัดทิ้งหรือช่วยทิ้ง
อ๋ออ๋อครูฟ้าทิ้งทำไมคนนี้กูฝันทิ้งผู้
ชายแข็งแรงครูฟ้าช่วยเด็กช่วยคนแก่
ไอต้องใช่ๆแข็งแรงว่ายน้ำโอเค
ขอครูฟ้าก็เลยกินเหล้าโอเคเด็กครูฟ้าช่วย
สมัยอยู่บนเรือคนแก่
ครูฟ้าช่วย
ผู้ชายแข็งแรงโครงฟ้า King ถูกต้องค่ะ
ถ้าเป็นครูหญิงล่ะ
ถ้าเป็นครูหญิงไม่ใช่ไหมอ่ะคนนี้เป็นครู
อีกนะวันนี้เป็นครูหญิงผู้หญิงมะผู้หญิง
ช่วยใครอย่าทิ้งใคร
หนิงจี๊ดๆเหมือนครูฟ้าเลยทำไมอ่ะแตกผู้
หญิงคิดเหมือนครูฟ้าหนึ่งอย่างก็คือเด็ก
ผู้ชายเด็กเนี่ยครูหญิงช่วยนะช่วยเด็ก
เนี่ยอยู่ที่นี่ผู้หญิงช่วยคนที่ 1 ก็คือ
เด็กคนที่ 1 หน้าคนที่สองครูหญิงช่วยก็
คือผู้ชายแข็งแรง
ทำไมเค้ารู้หญิงเพราะอะไรครูฟ้าภูฟ้าพาย
เรือมีลมมีหนมีพายุผู้ชายแข็งแรงเนี่ย
แข็งแรงไงก็ครูครูหญิงเด็กก็ไม่ตายเราไม่
รู้ใครเรือไฟเรือ
อ่าโอเคไหม
[เพลง]
ไส้แต่คนแก่ก็โอเคคนแก่ใช่ไหมคนแก่เนี่ย
ผู้หญิงทิ้งแก่แล้ว
มาคิดหรือฟ้าโอเคผู้ชายไม่ต้องผู้ชายแข็ง
แรงไม่ต้องกลัวฟ้า Only ครูฟ้าโอเคอ๋อครู
ฟ้าภัยเรียนคนเดียวโอเคน้องแต่ครูหญิงกับ
ครูฟ้าเหมือนกันก็คือเราเนี่ย
ช่วยเด็กผู้ใช่ไหมเราคิดเด็กเนี่ยต้องโต
โตโตอาหารแต่ว่าครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้า
ทิ้งผู้ชายแข็งแรงครูหญิง
ทิ้งคนแก่
น่ารักเรียนหรอคะนักเรียนคิดยังไงเหมือน
ครูฟ้าหรือมีผู้หญิงไหมก็ช้าอังกฤษเลยนะ
คะในสายค่ะนักเรียนจะช่วยสองคนใช่ไหมนัก
เรียนจะช่วยใครนักเรียนจะทิ้ง 1 คนนัก
เรียนจะทิ้งใครหน้าตัวเองไม่ได้นะอ้านัก
เรียนตัวนักเรียนไม่ได้นักเรียนคนที่พาย
เรือนักเรียนเหมือนครูหญิงเหมือนครูฟ้า
หนานักเรียนต้อง 3 คนใช่ไหมคะเด็กคนแก่คน
แข็งแรงนักเรียนช่วยใครทิ้งใครคอมเม้นท์
บอกเราได้สวยเหมือนคุณฟ้าบอกนะคะส่วน
วีดีโอนี้นะหาวีดีโอนี้ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้า
ก็ต้องไปก่อนแล้วเจอกันวีดีโอหน้านะคะ
บ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ